let's say you grow 2 000 subscribers
every month you just do the math and you
might go well sean it's gonna be like
three years until i get to 100 000
subscribers are you kidding me are you
like you did the math you reverse
engineer back from the target
and you go oh for three years it seems
so long my friend this viral world we
live in where unicorns blow up overnight
like not only is that not the norm but
also imagine if you were to go talk to
your grandfather or your grandmother who
grew up in a small town running a small
business and you're like
grandma i'm just complaining because
it's going to take me three years to get
to 100
000
humans
subscribed to my digital youtube channel
like are we can we talk in reality here
can we talk in real terms
like be patient like great things take
time
do you have a goal of getting your
youtube channel to a hundred thousand
subscribers do you wanna hold that
silver play button in your hands when
you reach that goal well i'm excited
because on today's episode of the think
media podcast we're diving into the
community questions and a question came
in from you about how to get to 100 000
subscribers my name is heather torres
and i am the host of the think media
podcast the number one podcast to help
you grow your influence on youtube and
then turn that influence into a high
impact and a high profit online business
i want to welcome you if this is your
first time to the podcast and if you're
returning thank you so much for being a
part of our community if you've not
already make sure you subscribe to the
podcast wherever you're consuming this
content we bring out a brand new episode
every single tuesday so you want to make
sure you're there for our tuesday ritual
well on today's episode we're getting
right into your questions so let's dive
into it right now
[Music]
what got you here
won't get you
there one of the biggest lessons i've
learned in business as well as youtube
is that a lot of times the activities
and the actions that it takes to say get
your first 100 or your first a thousand
or even 10 000 subscribers aren't
necessarily the same kind of activities
to get you to the next level this is
true in business you hit ceilings you
hit plateaus and so
we have different questions coming in
and specifically one of the people in
our community was talking about being at
17 000 subscribers let me know have you
crossed that 5 000 or 10 000 or 15 000
subscriber mark and are you now on that
next journey of how do i get to a
hundred thousand how do i get my silver
play button i wrote down a couple ideas
that i think um will really help you
grow if you're trying to scale to 100
000 subscribers on youtube and number
one is double down on
winning content
ask yourself what are the best
performing videos in my library
currently and a way to identify best
performing is of course your youtube
analytics will tell you your top viewed
videos your videos with the most minutes
watched your videos that are driving the
most subscribers
and your goal is make part twos we say
success leaves clues make part twos so
double down on the content that's
already already winning because that can
accelerate your subscriber growth
there's actually a very cool tool we use
from vid iq it's called the channel
audit tool and if you haven't actually
started using vid iq yet highly
recommended our affiliate link is
vidiq.com forward slash think and we'll
link that up in the show notes that'll
actually get you a free month of the
boost plan and you can use this channel
audit tool it tells you what content to
double down on but specifically it shows
you which videos have driven the most
subscribers
if you're defining your target is how do
i grow my subscribers faster you want to
make part twos of the actual videos that
are driving subscribers so what videos
are performing best in your library what
can you identify in your analytics of
your top videos of all time follow up
with those with another uh follow-up or
possibly a series build a whole series
around that video number two
increase your upload
quantity
now this might seem basic but how do i
get to a hundred 000 i'm getting what
i'm getting now
one of the best ways
to
grow faster on youtube
is to upload
more videos to youtube
wow sean i didn't know we were going to
get that deep on the podcast but i mean
it like if you can keep your quality
consistent
you're gonna grow twice as fast
theoretically if you upload twice as
many videos so the question is
okay how could i increase my upload
frequency because i know what you might
be thinking you're thinking man it's
it's hard enough to just get my one or
two videos uploaded a week i can't even
be consistent weekly when it comes to
editing and all of these other things
and it kind of reminds me i read a book
once called rich dad poor dad and it
said that you know uh robert kiyosaki
was saying there was two mentalities
when it came to like his poor dad was i
believe his biological father who kind
of was you know working and um you know
just kind of your nine-to-five job his
rich dad was like a mentor who sort of
was running businesses and thought a lot
about leverage and maximizing time and
so his thing was you know my poor dad
would say i can't afford it and my rich
dad would say how can i afford it
sometimes our mindset could say i can't
upload more videos but the unstoppable
mindset says
how can i upload more videos could i
simplify them could i hire somebody
could i chop some video like if you
figure it out and potentially you will
double your views
when you double your uploads
and even if you don't because it doesn't
work quite that linear
you're just giving yourself more at bats
more chances for a breakout video you
upload 10 videos a year you got 10
chances for a video to go viral or micro
viral
you upload 20 videos a year you just
doubled your chances chances so think
about how can i increase my upload
quantity number three how can i increase
my upload quality
now if you've been a part of the think
media podcast for any length of time you
know we encourage you get one percent
better with every upload well that's
great but ultimately it's not just you
know trying to get a little bit better
when i say quality
i actually mean how could i put out some
hitters some bangers how could i really
think about making
a hero video a video that has taken
extra some extra time in the topic some
extra time in the editing some extra
time in the big idea in the title
and really put something out because the
crazy thing about youtube is oftentimes
one breakout video one really
significant ranked video or one really
significant video that's really being
pushed by the algorithm can
disproportionately grow your
channel and so how can you upload
quality i don't just mean good lighting
i don't just mean a better camera in
fact that's probably not what's going to
move the needle the most i mean better
storytelling i mean a better hook i mean
just better understanding of who the
viewer is so ask yourself how can i
actually improve the quality of the
videos i'm putting out now that's going
to get you to 100 000 subscribers faster
number four experiment with new
video topics and formats i want to
congratulate you
if
you hit that five thousand ten thousand
seventeen thousand subscriber mark
you've accomplished a lot it's very
difficult
um to to hit those targets you've you've
crossed some major benchmarks i know it
has not come without work without pain
um if you've been consistent on youtube
no matter what your channel size for any
length of time
it's challenging and and i've been there
done that so i can i relate with what
you've been through but what can happen
in the grind of youtube the day-to-day
the consistency what happens is
sometimes you put your head down and you
even forget how hard you're working you
even forget you know the late nights of
editing or editing in between when the
kids are taking a nap or planning out
your videos you know a little bit here a
little bit there in between your chores
and work and other things you got going
on it's hard work especially when you're
hustling on the side
but what can happen
is we fall into a rut
we just fall into a rut of we we we
think we can only do it one way we fall
into a rut with our our creativity we
fall into a rut with our content formats
what do i mean by content formats we're
only doing talking head videos we hadn't
even sat down to think it'd be possible
to do a video that's kind of voice over
of b-roll and stock footage we're only
doing talking head videos we hadn't even
thought that it'd be possible to grab a
white board and do kind of like a draw
out a you know education or something on
on the whiteboard we hadn't even thought
it'd be possible to do like a webinar
style video over a keynote presentation
or powerpoint presentation i'm just
saying different content form we hadn't
even thought about inviting some people
to interview on our channel using stream
yard we haven't thought about
kind of shaking up the apple cart of the
way we've been doing things on our
channel and if you want to trigger
growth
consider experimenting
with new video topics and formats
now
you want to know what is your brand and
your value proposition and who you're
trying to reach
but i promise you friend like we can
sometimes get into a creative rut and
just like writers have writer block we
writer's block we have video block
but there's unlimited possibilities for
you when you step to youtube it is a
blank canvas
the music the words you say the videos
the way you edit who you collaborate
with what you do like there's so much
creativity there but sometimes we just
get in a rut so how could you
get out of that rut and here's one of
the big tips on here if we get really
nitty-gritty on this journey
from say
zero to ten thousand versus zero to a
hundred thousand
often times when you're starting a
youtube channel from scratch i really
recommend search-based content be
the method you use to grow your channel
now that doesn't mean you ever have to
ever stop using search-based content we
continue to do it all day every day at
think media but especially when you're
starting
you don't really have like a seed
audience you don't really have it's
almost like when you're building your
first group of subscribers you're
building a street team you're building a
group of people
that will
engage with your uploads and you have
almost like a test group a small group
that if they really love an upload that
you post
that then youtube sees
the a thousand subscribers ten thousand
subscribers on your channel engage with
that so they start
sharing it with others
so when you start your channel
search based is a good way to start
long tail keywords very niche topics you
start getting that basis of viewership
but if you really want to scale your
youtube channel fast suggested based
videos are one of the best ways to do it
and never forget that 75 of traffic on
youtube comes from youtube's algorithm
recommending videos to people so what i
mean is
in think media we might do a video like
how to do a jump cut in adobe premiere
just a very practical search based video
probably never it would never probably
go viral it might get a million views
over four years because it's utility and
people are looking for it but a
suggested base video
it might be something around
a trending topic it might be the title's
not so practical the title is
this weird video editing secret
saved me hours
that's that suggested mentality a little
more mystery in the thumbnail so what
i'm suggesting and we can't really
unpack this whole idea but number four
is if you get out of your rut experiment
with new video topics and new video
formats and maybe if you've really been
subscriber by subscriber growing with
search based you can scale to a hundred
thousand subscribers faster by shifting
your mentality into suggested based
types of videos and again uh for more on
that if you haven't seen you know our
podcast or our master class you can
always go to thinkmasterclass.com
and we we go deeper on really crafting
content
and some nuances with that because i
know that was maybe a deeper concept and
so uh that free class is at
thinkmasterclass.com number five man how
do i scale
to a hundred thousand subscribers hire
help
higher hope
and ask yourself is it time to hire help
now if you're new to the think media
podcast i encourage you to check our
library out on apple or spotify or in
the youtube video library because we
have an episode with tips on when to
hire
on youtube but i encourage you to hire
help because now let's think about it
you've already got some momentum
you've already
got to ten thousand subs twenty thousand
so
how do you go faster well you gotta
recognize you still only have 24 hours
in a day
but when you start working with somebody
else you're multiplying your efforts
you're able to do go further faster
because there's more people working on
the channel even if that's someone
helping five hours a week with
administrative work and delegating video
editing you could regain 10 20 hours a
week depending on how much time you're
spending video editing so
that's gonna you go back to how can i
increase my upload quantity and quality
one way could be to hire help and it
just kind of reminds me of my journey
you know i went full time on youtube
at 16 000 subscribers by necessity
because my my freelance clients all let
me go three freelance clients in three
weeks time one was paying me 1 000 a
month and the other two are paying me 2
000 a month so about 60 000 a year from
these three freelance clients but three
weeks in a row october 2015 they all
fired me
so after the fourth week of ben and
jerry's and netflix and just trying to
get my emotional confidence back i
decided to go all in on youtube and i
was at
000 subscribers on think media and so i
went all in
i'll tell you this
step one
i did exactly what i'm telling you to do
here i double down on the videos i knew
would work double down on winning
content
i increased my upload quantity by myself
editing shooting titles hustling i ex i
increased my upload quality i was no
longer doing freelance work i you know
hustling on things i started to
experiment a little bit but i've
actually focused heavily on search-based
content and practical utility content
and content that was could be monetized
that was very
profit-based because i was trying to
actually make youtube a full-time thing
i was trying to recover the five
thousand dollars a month that i lost to
say hey can i actually do this youtube
channel so i was very focused on the
topics i was doing
and i immediately started thinking about
hiring help help started to come in
whether it was someone that just kind of
volunteered and was an intern and then i
hired him on and a contractor and in
those days heather taurus was started
helping us build out products
and she worked for free at first on a
percentage of products that didn't exist
yet because
she had a vision for the future she's an
entrepreneur she's an intrapreneur she's
like all right yeah i'll work on when
this thing sells even if we don't start
selling this thing for eight months
and but it was this higher help
mentality and there's no question again
what i'm telling you is the mindset of
hiring help to think for me to get from
10k to 100k subs
i i don't know if i can afford it yet
still think about it i don't know if i
can actually make that jump yet still be
thinking about it be looking at how you
could do it remember the mindset
i can't hire help
the other question how can i hire help
how could
i hire help who could potentially help
me could i enlist a family member to
volunteer for a few months with the
potential with with real targets hey if
you help me hit this particular amount
of monthly revenue
open open transparency hey friend like
if we can get this to this youtube thing
to generating 5k a month or 10k a month
when we cross that threshold i'll cut
you in and and i'll start paying you
2500 a month so let's try to build
together i know you got a little extra
time and we have a vision for this
how could i enlist somebody to help me
could you get interns from a local you
know media college or local college
working in the film department that need
credit
could you
you know get a volunteer somebody that
wants to partner with what you're doing
that is at your local church or could
you just pony up the money and reinvest
the dollars from your
15 000 subscriber youtube channel
into
other people to help you scale faster
rather than taking all of the seed
you've gathered so far and quitting your
day job maybe you kind of stay anchored
in your day job invest that money into
building a team around your side hustle
so that it blows up faster
hire help
you want to get to a hundred thousand
subscribers fast faster those are a
couple ideas and then finally kind of a
bonus tip
is uh
do the math and be patient
so
when i say do the math
ask yourself this question go into your
youtube analytics
and see how many subscribers your
channel grows every month
more accurately see how many subscribers
your channel grew in the last six months
the math of how long it's going to take
you to get to 100 000 subscribers would
be revealed there
so
let's say you grow 2 000 subscribers
every month
you just do the math and you might go
well sean it's gonna be like three years
until i get to a hundred thousand
subscribers are you kidding me are you
like you did the math you reverse
engineer back from the target
and you go oh for three years it seems
so long my friend this viral world we
live in where unicorns blow up overnight
like not only is that not the norm but
also
imagine if you were to go talk to your
grandfather or your grandmother who grew
up in a small town running a small
business and you're like
grandma i'm just complaining because
it's going to take me three years to get
to 100
000
humans
subscribed to my digital youtube channel
like are we can we talk in reality here
can we talk in real terms
like be patient like great things take
time like would you be okay
if five years from now then you get your
silver play button like everybody wants
a medal for the work after doing work
for seven days it'd be like an employee
comes to you and it's like hey i've
worked at the company for seven days can
i get a gold medal
no you can get a lacroix from the
company refrigerator and get back to
work great things take time bruh and so
do the math
and then just be like you it might just
be okay like listen what if you just
didn't grow faster what if you just grew
healthily over time you're like oh yeah
i am growing a thousand subscribers a
month so it's gonna take me 52 months to
get there if i can just sustain what i'm
doing now and i'll be okay with that
like not everything has to be viral and
that's super significant sometimes slow
growth is healthy growth so do the math
and be patient
you know i've said in the past
that youtube is
a marathon and not a sprint
and then my friend roberto blake once i
heard him say he goes you know actually
youtube's it's more like an ultra
marathon it's not a sprint and i'm like
sure bro i'm sure you would one-up me
like that and then i heard somebody else
recently say dude youtube's like an iron
man
not a sprint and i'm like where are we
going with this like what like what are
these analogies so so i've i'm gonna one
up everybody
youtube is like an epic five not a
sprint
not it doesn't hit as hard cause nobody
knows what that is if you haven't heard
the epic five it's five iron mans on
five hawaiian islands in one week rich
roll and this other guy did it
so i'm just trying to one up my peers
you get the point at the point is
you great things take time be patient
it's not a sprint
to a hundred thousand
youtube is an epic five iron man five
iron mans on five hawaiian islands it's
exhausting it takes time so pace
yourself get your mind locked in for
battle get your mind locked in for slow
and steady wins
be grateful for every step on the
journey do the math think about how you
can make small tweaks to increase your
growth and your subscriber growth but
just embrace the journey embrace the
process it's gonna be okay and that that
silver play button is gonna feel so
great imagine picture the emotions
you know even think about what you'll
feel like when youtube mails you that
silver play button on the other side of
all the work in all the late nights and
the videos that won and the seasons and
even the months
where growth growth was extra slow but
then those times when growth was faster
those seasons will kind of merge
together and you'll look back with
gratitude with confidence with
appreciation of the sacrifice and the
hard work that you put in to get there
so be patient and never forget
youtube is an ultra marathon iron man
epic five and not a sprint
well i hoped that that content helped
you figure out how you can start moving
towards that 100 000 subscriber goal and
i have some action items for you some
questions to ask you around what do you
need to do next where do you need to
take action on your youtube channel to
help you get to that 100 000 subscribers
out of those tips which action do you
want to take do you need to make part
twos here's a tip you don't actually
have to label it part two in the title
it's just your knowledge of knowing it's
a part two to a video that's been doing
really great what videos are performing
best on your channel have you have you
gone into your analytics have you seen
what videos are actually performing how
are you seeing what videos are working
and what videos aren't which ones can
you dive into more and more
do you need to increase your uploads i
know this is something that i'm always
thinking about how can i make this
process easier how can i make two videos
instead of one video how can i get more
eyeballs on my channel what do you need
to do differently do you need to
simplify your videos do you need to make
two videos instead of one that are
easier to make rather than one hard long
video do you need to make your videos
better maybe the quality of the video
could increase maybe adding b-roll or
understanding the storyline more all of
these things can help you increase how
long people stay on your videos and how
many people are finding them ultimately
in the end
should you test new video types or
structures or content formulas i think
this is one thing that we challenge so
many of our think community members with
the idea of just because you've done
something doesn't mean that's the only
way you have to do it could you go live
could you make a where you're doing q
a's just like this where you don't
necessarily have to spend a ton of time
making before and after videos or
something like that and do you need help
i mean honestly think about this is this
something you need to be looking forward
to in your business
should you be getting someone to help
you part-time with the kids do you need
help with editing again like sean said
it doesn't have to be someone that you
pay an enormous amount for it could be
someone who just wants to be a part of
the vision that you're on maybe it's
someone who you could uh use the adsense
revenue to pay for their editing skills
or maybe you need someone to help you
with thumbnails or building out the back
end of your business
where do you need help and is that the
next step for you most people who are
succeeding on youtube right now are not
doing this alone so take that to heart
when you think about what you need to do
next to get to a hundred thousand
subscribers well i wanna thank you so
much for being a part of this think
podcast community and thank you so much
for the people who have left a review
and rated the podcast i would love to
encourage you to go over and do that
next if you haven't already and i want
to shout out uh jem today i love that
jem said this is the free99 university
that's right this podcast is completely
free jem says their content is so worth
listening to i've gone to their
conference and their episodes are very
much like it so listen
learn it's worth it well thank you so
much jem for being a part of our
community leaving that review and
letting us know uh that this is the
podcast for you that's right this is
free and it is like a university level
and i want to let you know about one
more thing if you've not taken our free
youtube class that is your next step we
have a brand new youtube class ready and
waiting for you at thinkmasterclass.com
and on this class sean's going to be
showing you the one simple youtube
strategy where he turned 130 into 19
323
with one single youtube
video make sure you register for that
free class if you want to take advantage
and learn how we think really
strategically about youtube and how you
can do the same thing well thank you so
much for being a part of this community
and we'll catch you on the next episode
bye
you